we are back here for another episode
episode is brought to you by distilled
jeans I pronounced it wrong awesome
saying D STL denim but it's Julianne
you're supposed to be on my team general
luxury great denim really awesome denim
great styles starting at just 65 bucks
really awesome jeans right now you can
get 10 bucks off your first pair we're
going to DST LD dot-com slash Jenna
Julianne that's distilled jeans guys
check it out also brought to you by the
wonderful and one and only me undies
which currently is providing a bed for
mr. marbles on I love me I need so much
they're so good to us and they make such
an incredible product their underwear is
twice as soft as cotton it's made from
micro motile fabric and they have the
dopest designs out of any underwear you
can find right now guys get 20% off your
first order going to me Indies comm
slash Jenna Julian Thank You Mandy's
Thank You Distilled Thank You sponsors I
feel good it really is like she likes
this this is how I used to sit at my
desk when I used to work at a desk
pat-down - all day every day you'd said
just like this not with me undies though
but just like a little t-shirt or a
blanket just sit on my desk he's so good
when he's alone like this like yeah he
doesn't misbehave when he's a long
period yeah man good boy he just wants
him alone
dear cute boy huh your cute little boy
might be you staying at me he's staring
at me for those not watching you're
listening so as promised we wanted to
talk about let's talk about ghosts okay
so what goes because last time we talked
about death Halloween it's completely
appropriate and you guys asked for it so
this is also your fault so next week we
just like we're gonna get even darker
and then darker oh wow I'm ready I'm
here for this here for this alright so
what I did was I went up on the World
Wide Web and I compiled like a few
theories I figured we would kind of do
the same thing that we devised yeah and
go through these theories and kind of
just discuss each one I like that oh my
God he's in heaven right now so let's
start with well first of all do you want
to go through any ghost stories or
anyone do that after because I don't
have those stories but I know you have a
couple yeah I have a couple um why don't
why don't if mine we go through some of
these series known you and bring them up
so first there is ghosts are spirits of
dead people mm-hmm okay basically pretty
straightforward someone died and they
are now in the world on earth in the
form of a ghost mm-hmm and I guess this
can happen for a number of reasons right
someone like when a house is haunted
with someone maybe something happened to
them in that house or at a certain
location a person died what is your take
on that whole thing because I know that
that's a really popular theory that
ghosts are spirits or spirits of dead
people I feel like so I've watched a
fair amount of ghost hunters and stuff
like that I feel like it's people that
don't pass on for whatever reason
there's some stuff that happens and then
it's also their energy and it's
bound to like a certain object or place
like you don't hear a lot of ghosts that
are just like free roaming around the
world and you know do whatever I've
heard of people limited to one specific
claiming that you know a ghost follows
them some places or but it's attached to
a person you know or a place or a thing
um demons I feel like when people talk
about that those things have no rules
and no [ __ ]
but for ghosts the spirits of dead
people I feel like it's their energy is
like somehow latched on to something
that means something to them or a person
or a place or a thing but I do I totally
buy into the idea that ghosts are
spirits of dead people yeah so that's
probably the one that you would most
likely align with them yep right off the
bat so there's just jump in your
experience is that and what are your
what is your take on what happened yeah
so I I'd say one of the first ones ever
it was I was in an all-girls camp called
wells college and it was like a
leadership camp for young teenage girls
to go and you know cry about their
feelings and learn how to be adults sort
of so it was all girls and we stayed in
the dorms and the campus is like
relatively haunted you know they tell
you all the stories when you get there
some of the stories were like parts of
the dorm used to be an old stable that
burned down so at night sometimes you
can hear horses one of the rooms also
got burned down was a someone that was a
writer
you could hear a typewriter at night um
that's probably there's a bridge that
goes across the campus it was said that
somebody like some widow was waiting up
on her thing and her husband was
cheating on her so she stabbed him so
like often times the lights on one end
of the bridge would go out when you're
walking across it at night but like only
when you were walking across it it's not
like they were just flicker the weirdest
one to me was so in upstate New York
where Wells College is one of the
stories was in the winter when there was
like I forget what it was like the flu
or pneumonia or something was going
around and
a lot of people died and you can't bury
bodies in the winter because the ground
is frozen so you can't dig them a grave
yeah so all these people were dying over
the winter due to illness and so they
had a room where they were putting the
bodies and they painted the door bright
red so that they can you know know which
room was and not to go in it and
whenever they tried to paint over it or
remove the paint or anything it would
come off and the door was always red I
was weird that one really just doesn't
sit well with me I don't get it like
they try to remove the red paint yeah
and it wouldn't come nothing and they
try to paint over it and everything
would peel off of it oh my god yeah
okay that's pretty crazy Wow
but so I was there and everybody I was
you know not for or against ghosts or
whatever just hadn't had any experiences
with it and it was a little bit spooky
like you hear all the stories and I was
saying in a dorm room with my friend
that I went to the camp with at the time
and it was really late and she always
fell asleep like right away
and I just I'm not like that I sort of
stay up and pondered the universe so I'm
laying in my bed and my roommate is
asleep and all of a sudden I felt like
the end of my bed like really sink down
like someone was sitting on it and like
I looked at it and you could see like an
impression like it was dark but you
could still see enough oh yeah it's your
bedroom no it's black so it was a
completely dark so you felt it and then
you looked and saw yeah because I'm
laying on my back like this and I'm
looking at it and I don't know if you've
ever wouldn't get into it if you've ever
had that experience like I've had
experiences like that in my life where
the only thing I compare it to is seeing
a ghost or feeling like you see a ghost
like your body you just sort of like
shuts down out of pure fear like you're
doing I couldn't like yell at my
roommate if I wanted to I couldn't sit
up and like freak out if I wanted to I
was sort of paralyzed by fear at the
feeling of someone sit
on my bed and then this was this various
weird but I looked up over my bed and
there was a like Mountain Dew colored
cross on the wit like the wall that was
illuminated and like the windows were
shut everything was off and there was a
cross above my bed and I felt like
someone was sitting on the foot of my
bed hold on hold on so the cross existed
in the room it was just lighting up no
it didn't exist it was nothing it looked
like a projection of a mountain dew
color like green yellow cross above my
bed that's what I'm saying it doesn't
make any sense I did it did it look like
a physical object or a projection oh
look it was just white it was like yeah
so the next morning I woke up and I was
like cuz eventually I fell asleep I
don't remember falling asleep at all I
just remember freaking out and then the
night goes by I wake up the next morning
I tell my friend and I'm like this is
what happened to me and she was like I
was awake and she saw the cross above my
bed and she just thought you're asleep
and insane neither of us could do
anything so but she even killed the
person sitting on the bed no that was
only to tell her about it yes what'd you
say what's freaking out obviously she
hyped
Tartan know no one was hyped it was
nothing fun about it okay so explain to
me what you think happened like on every
single level of that situation um I mean
there's no rational explanation for why
there was a like here's the crate I'm
gonna cut you off sorry okay
what sorry I know I asked you a question
then cut you right off I just here's the
thing for me is like I haven't had a
personal ghost experience I just have it
it's not happy we ought to go and get
you one but when I hear people that I
trust say that I swear this happened it
becomes real for me because I trust like
you and Rome told me that one time in
you know wherever we were she was
telling us about that ghost and she was
like I swear then I was like okay if I
can believe you so gone there's no
rational explanation for a lit-up cross
on the wall none
I mean maybe I just I can't explain why
do you think it was across like what of
any object going back do you think it
was like assign some meaning to this no
I don't it wasn't satanic the cross
wasn't upside down
I honestly because that campus all of it
is so steeped in that you know ghost
history like there's a lot of things
that's well known yeah it's not like you
were like completely surprised right but
I also wasn't scared of it happening I
was scared in the moment while it was
happening I'm not because I think ghosts
are troubled spirits or people that are
still there I don't know that's right go
that's against the law mystery ghosts
it's against the region because I don't
think that most ghosts want to harm you
they're just like maybe misguided or
they get attached to you or they like
you or maybe they don't like you um I
think that there's not ghosts but that
there wasn't some sort of like
threatening presence about it yeah I
mean backwards but if I look back on it
and I had to assign some meaning to it
it felt like someone was staring at me
the entire time because that was one of
the original reasons I guess I forgot to
say that that I was sort of not sleeping
or when I was sleeping I wasn't sleeping
well because it did it felt like someone
was staring at you in that room all the
time and that's not something that I can
really explain in any other way it's
just it feels like someone is staring at
you while you're trying to sleep any of
your eyes closed you know you like you
you jolt awake sometimes or you look
around because you're like it really
feels like someone is just staring into
the feeling of being watched is a very
distinct feeling I've ever had it with
something like that but I know what
you're talking about
um but I think honestly if you wanted me
to assign some meaning to it if it just
felt like that was somebody's room and I
was in their room and they just wanted
to make their presence known yeah you
know
yeah I mean that's the it's interesting
it's just interesting these experience
is like as much as I really don't want
to experience something as I apply with
[ __ ] my pants about it it's like I kind
of want to experience they like for
myself so you can go places I don't want
to do that's a bloomin tourist industry
you stay at these old terrifying places
not for me it's like just like you know
[ __ ] skiing and [ __ ] it's not for you
just no not for me yeah I'm younger it's
it is really terrifying while it's
happening because it's well when you
watch shows about ghosts and stuff a lot
of them explain them in measureable
energy forces you know ghost hunters and
stuff when they the EVP is that the
that's the sound I forget what the
energy is they see white orbs when they
do pictures and stuff because they
explain it in terms of energy so if you
go with that idea yeah just by being in
the presence of a relatively haunted
place or area you feel it you know but
you can't you can't measure it I guess
if you have those tools but even that
doesn't prove anything all you go on is
just that you feel this presence you
know because it's energy yeah another
theory but we can move on to now I guess
is one that doesn't like oh sorry it's
not any me long I just wanted to lay
these two theories good you can go to a
grocery but like this other theory is
basically like it's similar to the two
them this last area of it's a dead
person's spirit but it kind of goes
alongside it and the theory is that like
when there was a certain event that was
recorded to a location in the world
mm-hmm
forever like it's recorded into the
universe and so little remnants of that
replay in the form of a ghost mm-hmm so
that's kind of similar to these things
you're seeing like the trails of the
event continuing to happen in some other
dimension no it's like yes but it's like
it's almost like you're watching on loop
right part of that event that had
happened at one point in human history I
guess my only problem with that theory
is that maybe that's true for some like
supernatural experiences
but that doesn't explain a lot of
people's experiences that don't appear
to be on any loop yeah look if you watch
those television shows of like though if
you know a little boy possesses a bed or
something after he dies and everyone
that sleeps in it they get scratched in
the face and like crazy shit's happening
so they leave a piece of paper on the
bed with a pen and the boy of writes out
like this is my dad like please leave me
alone
where does where does that TV show
haunted something haunted that's scary
is that show is really scared that story
you just told like scared me right now
well that's tough like those are real
accounts of people that have had really
messed up things I believe it but not as
much as I believe that it's like can you
tell me you saw it well that's fine I I
hope that I don't ever have a story like
that to tell me well you know how that
resolved itself her is that someone a
really nice woman bought the bed and
agreed to just keep it in her attic by
itself so that that boy could have his
bed so she's cool it's just like a ghost
upstairs yeah all he wanted was his bed
and she says they they don't have any
problems they don't see him they don't
hear him there's nothing going on he
just he wanted his bed he just won his
bet if I died now as a ghost that would
be the one thing I wanted to I just feel
like yo I'm [ __ ] tired let me sleep no
he was a little boy thanks and he died
in the bed no no I think yeah it doesn't
it doesn't necessarily have to be where
you died hmm yeah that's another thing
I'm interested is like the rule book I
don't think there's a rule but the rule
book the manual the man well well if you
think of it in terms of energy if you
died and then there's some place or some
person or something that has like really
strong significance to you that you're
really longing for something maybe your
energy could in theory manifest in that
place so for me it'd be like the kitchen
well yeah to be like the Julian tornado
has haunting in the house I mean there's
tons of stories of people being like you
know my grandmother my mother passed
away and she used to love potato chips
and then you know a week after she died
there's a bunch of potato chips all over
the floor that spilled all over the
floor you know maybe that happens for
like once or twice but it's it's a thing
Wow
as their soul is going somewhere else I
don't know you might go to the other
story oh I was just looking at an
apartment one time and we went down into
the basement and it felt so wrong
everything down there felt terrifying I
was like I have to get out of here and
so we started walking up the stairs did
you say something or no no I was just
the the real estate agent was showing us
the basement and I was like okay yeah no
this is totally fine but I'm
I've seen enough I'd like to go back
upstairs so the real estate agent walks
up and we start walking up the stairs
and all of a sudden we started hearing
footsteps following us up these wooden
stairs because in Boston a lot of places
had these like dirt basements they're
not that you've heard the footsteps oh
my god I started running up the stairs I
was like thank you this is not the
apartment for me I'm gonna get out of
here holy [ __ ] yeah it was ridiculous
you think like I mean you think of a
place was haunted that the spirits would
at least mask themselves until a person
moved in right not necessarily that's
not in the rule book but I don't think
there is a robust okay that's crazy well
what do you think ghosts are I see
that's a thing like I the story about
the boy in his bed the story about
[ __ ] you know people having there's
millions of stories I know and that's
the thing in like I I believe that they
exist I believe that ghosts are a real
thing and I I honestly don't think
there's one theory to explain all ghosts
I think some ghosts are explained by
dead people spirits and other ghosts are
explained by a varying number of things
like looking through this list of
theories kind of made me realize that
it's it seems just kind of impossible
that all ghosts are explained by one
thing I just I really I like the idea
that dogs can see ghosts and children
can see ghosts because I had a friend in
high school whose nephew was doing that
he literally was playing with a guy on
the stairs every single day every day he
was on the stairs and he would tell his
mother every day and playing with
so-and-so on the stairs
like a grown man like it happens and I
feel like kids and dogs and people's
whose brains aren't completely you know
decided that this is something that
can't be possible that you can't explain
your mind why kids see ghosts yeah
they see them you know they'll tell you
what they look like yeah and dogs will
bark it goes yeah Wow it's also um a
theory or people in the ghost world that
guess say that if you like if you own a
home and you renovate parts of it you do
run the risk of like stirring up some
sort of spirit or energy by doing that I
give you so it's basically disturbing
their peace okay yeah I believe that
right yeah have you ever gone down the
rabbit hole of like Indian burial
grounds like Native American burial
grounds no not trying to be offensive no
just don't just don't have a Harvest
Festival where there are like places
where you can go and like sit on things
and get pushed off no yes take me there
I'll do that no they're not around here
babe where are they you just said you
didn't I don't want to stay over at a
haunted house and sleep in a haunted
room but I'll go sit on a stump and get
pushed off we I'm sure for Halloween
around here we could find something the
the craziest part about the East Coast
though I feel like is because there's so
many older places there are like
well-known established areas where you
can go and have a haunted experience or
at least feel what it feels like to be
in a place like that I would do that in
affected places in LA aside from all the
murder houses there has to be there has
to be we can go on a ghost bus tour
didn't mean it then it goes bust or I'm
gonna be a ghost because I'm dead from
that joke so bad I'm so sorry
I'm so
[Music]
yeah that was those rough that was a
good dye job done nice job what else you
got oh you can adapt sit or thank you
other theories yeah okay so we got the
next one is it's their entities not
necessarily people but entities living
entities from other dimensions or
realities that are currently just like
peeking into your world but they're not
dead they're still they're alive however
you want that to make any sense but if
you can imagine an alternate universe an
alternate dimension those people are
living there liar living their lives
we're just seeing the like trail
remnants of it you're seeing reflection
of it oh yeah yeah like that's that's
that's one thing that I can't say that
doesn't exist with everything I don't
really possibly like you'd be stupid to
say they perceive whoever they're you
know perceiving as the ghosts so maybe
he's combative people these combative
ghosts are just living their real lives
and they see you as a combatant really
possible I love that idea I think that's
so intriguing because it's like the idea
of a ghost right the idea of like a like
a figure like very faint it's such a
great representation generation but it's
such a great representation in my mind
of like what someone from another
dimension looks like to us and what mean
we may look like to them like I don't
know that you can theorize and think
about it for so long in your head of
alternate universes and you know
currently happening dimensions right
next to you but in a parallel whatever
but the idea of like a physical ghost
that is that that fits into the picture
really well for me
you know what I mean that kind of just
makes a lot of sense yeah I mean I've
never seen an apparition I've never seen
a ghost okay you just don't recall yeah
but so take my experience for example if
I really felt like every night I was
going to bed and there were somebody
sleeping in my bed and I couldn't
explain that feeling to you like this is
so weird like it feels like there's
someone already sleeping in my bed I
might sit
because I can't see this person it feels
like they're sitting down and staring at
me yeah but perhaps that person in
another dimension is sitting on their
bed you know maybe on their knees and
being like what what's going on here is
there a person here you know but all I
can feel is the sitting motion and the
staring motion in my dimension but I
guess if I was that person and I felt
like someone was sleeping in my bed I'd
just sit there and trying to figure out
they're not just like the most sense
right it just makes no sense likes the
most sitting on your bed it's very
possible you're sitting in your bed but
who's to say that that bed isn't also in
another universe and is someone else
someone else is dead and you're making
the indent for them and freaking them
out like who's there or watching them
yeah I'm just saying what that makes a
lot of sense my but that's easy to copy
I just I like that what's possible yeah
it doesn't explain everything nothing
it's nothing explains everything that
I'm aware of
I mean correct me if I'm wrong and also
in the comments feel free to share your
ghost stories because I like reading
them yeah I think so does that really
kind of maybe not everyone yeah I just I
would love to have a ghost encounter but
on my terms I wouldn't want to piss my
pants and if I did piss my pants I would
like them to be distilled oh my god
because they are quite amazing jeans
luxury amazing material really really
well built Jenna put hers on the other
day she showed us the bot I was wearing
these earlier I the only reason I'm not
wearing right now is because I'm a hot
and it's hot as [ __ ] in this room but
super comfortable guys distilled has
revolutionized fashion industry by
making timeless luxury great denim
starting at just $65 these jeans would
normally cost you hundreds of dollars
and they do it because they refuse to
work with department stores and retail
no no man there's no markup no [ __ ]
just a great Jean yeah at an
unbelievable price it's awesome so just
go to D STL decom slash Jenna Julianne
and you get $10 off your first pair and
you can look through all their styles
and they'll ship it right to your door
which is awesome if you don't like the
fit if you don't like the Jean
they'll send you a new pair until you're
happy
I see one see for yourself why a list
celebrities a list not like F list like
a list celebrities have been spotted in
magazines like Vogue and GQ we're on the
wine list and I see the wine list even
c-list celebrities yeah so these jeans
which style are the items hood I don't
know they're comfortable as [ __ ] let me
see Superman they're like high-waisted
no cute yeah oh and the packaging is
nice even - what is it say right here
oh design in Los Angeles it doesn't say
what style though no no they're just the
dope style I guess guys right now go to
DST LD coms last Jenna Julianne get ten
bucks off first pair let us know you
like it it's just still denim also this
week if I pissed my pants I would like
to be wearing me I need because is
easily the softest underwear I've ever
put they're so cute the winds that they
just gave us the monkey with um camo but
it also looks like those are ghost camos
it goes cameras oh jeez you guys are so
good to us you send this underwear every
month it's like a relationship yeah you
guys can have that relationship too
you just go to me at ease comm
scheduling you get 20% off your first
order and you can get the subscription
where you get the new designs every
single month they focus on making the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced they sent me a bunch of
pairs as you can see right here this is
literally like 1/10 of the Julian wears
at this point yeah you don't own a pair
you've seen all my Calvin oh I'm so
sorry that was so sad oh poor Julie
guys for the price of 2 condors it's
just so sad before for the price of two
cocktails meetings with deliver you your
favorite pair of underwear right to your
doorstep it's such an awesome thing guys
it's proven scientifically proven with a
touch of modal in their fabric
three times softer than cotton tight
tight tight enemy and he's not calm
sighs Jenna Julian 20% off your first
order unless I like it tweet us pictures
of your Mandy's thank you sponsor yeah
we love you I love you mom well scared
[Music]
all right angels and demons okay what do
you think about that those that ghosts
are angels and our demons okay I totally
believe that demons exist I totally
believe that okay because of the the
stories that I feel like I've read and
seen on TV of people being like this was
not a a ghost this was not you know what
this is a they're possessing something
or someone or their demonic in nature
and they don't act like a ghost this is
like you wish it was a ghost because
they just don't care they hurt you
they'll actually scratch you like it's
physically harmed or an account and
isn't a Incubus isn't am I saying that
right
I can't no it's when a ghost or and I'm
sorry a demon rapes you Oh tight right
like this is a real thing that exists
that people is really what that whole
season of American Horror Story was
which one don't wear the demon rapes the
guy in the hotel the drill [ __ ] yeah we
didn't we didn't finish watching that
season because it was so bad it was not
for me I didn't sign up for American
absolute shock and gore to a television
way too much we didn't finish it so
after that draft let's do anyway I'm
sorry we go do this too much for me and
it's gonna take a lot to kind of bring
us back onto that band
and I started watching the new season in
there because I feel like I'm so tapped
out we can't be alone in that yes I a
thousand percent believe the demons
exist because of people's accounts of
them and that they do really what I want
to know what if you're a person who
experiences go straight or at least you
think you don't right not go straight
it's a demon it's very different you
think a demon [ __ ] you but it's
invisible right like you can't point to
any like that's that's not that's not
true at all there's people that claim
that they see them doing okay so here's
my question if a person experiences this
or the things they do and they go get a
rape kit what's in the rape kit
probably nothing that's crazy but they
have visible a lot of these people claim
that they or they've showed that they
have visible like scratches and bruising
and things like that on them but it's
not you can't explain it with a rape kit
I guess that I guess yeah I'm just
posing questions here no it's a valid
question in your mind if you were to say
a demon encounter on earth where the
human being looks like this what would
it look like in terms of the demon in
your mind like if you were to say like I
don't know I saw I saw a ghost
I saw a demon what's the difference like
what do you think it is well I feel like
traditionally people have described
demons as like combative as dark as evil
like they they are not just a lost
person you know maybe scaring you but
also people describe ghosts as some of
them being very fearful and like
withdrawn like they they don't want to
be seen they're nervous or they're
scared but I've never heard someone
explain their experience with a demon as
like yeah he just sort of lurked around
like they they are malicious yeah yes
and okay so my question is if if they if
that's a thing like what causes that to
be the thing like is it a really bad
person who died no demons are totally
different
as do I think angels are totally
different
some people think that angels are like
you know your grandmother or people once
they get into heaven become an angel and
cook but I think that there's another
theory that angels are different all
together and that you can't you know die
and go to heaven and become an angel
look at how angel yeah I know yeah
definitely like Michael and I don't know
they have names
yes Michael for me and so people don't
become demons they're demonic forces
they're entities that is not human at
all as it makes sense where they come
from negative energy I mean I don't have
the answer to that no no just honest
thing I'm just asking you because you
know more than me and you a better idea
that's all well I think if you were to
believe in an angels or demons that
would sort of imply that you believe
that there's beings in this world or
that interact with this world that don't
come from this world so you can't really
explain what it is it just it's a demon
would you do you think demons can exist
in human form
yes so okay that that intrigues me well
think of all the exorcism that happened
cross-culturally like people claiming
that they're being possessed by a demon
or being bothered by a demon or there's
accounts of people claiming that they're
possessed or that someone that they love
is possessed and you hear all those them
speaking in tongues and you know doing
crazy [ __ ] it's terrifying yeah I think
it is possible for a demon to take a
human form and I don't know even fly
under the radar that's what that's crazy
to me like I'm wondering if I've ever
met a person so miserable are such a
terrible energy person who is what was
consumed by a demon when I met them like
that how you never know you never know
right
I mean maybe that is a crazy idea but I
I genuinely do believe that because I've
bought into the idea of demons yeah just
because of the pure volume of people
that claim that they exist yeah it's you
know good enough for me I do believe
that they can possess a human form you
someone's current body they could
possess you know you Julian
or they could manifest themselves as a
person Wow
crazy right yeah I don't want to deal
with the demon yeah no but that's why
you know the whole Ouija board and stuff
like that they say like that stuff's
really messed up even if the Ouija board
is just you know a little Mattel game or
whatever it is but the ritual of sort of
asking spirits and asking people to come
visit you if you're not prepared or
you're not coming with peace and you're
not coming with like light you are
running the risk of opening a portal or
becoming a portal for demonic entities
to come into your life or you know
affect the people around you you feel
like that subject things with the wrong
energy you could be [ __ ] yourself
absolutely because it's not the game
it's something the game is just a medium
it's it's a pathway no but you don't
even need the game we could just be
sitting here holding hands with some
candles asking you know whoever to come
visit us and talk with us and by doing
that by opening your energy you can that
way invite anybody or anything that
wants to come in this aura well so my
friend in high school her mom was a
psychic and literally had this game
called the psychic circle which we like
to play which was not Ouija at all but
it was like maybe it wasn't the psychic
circle I can't remember the name of the
game but it was like you you lit certain
candles you did things in a certain way
you open it everything has to be like
very open very kind and there's really
specific steps of how you do things and
then everything gets closed at the end
you're not allowed to be like oh my god
this is scary
ah and then run out of the ring of
therapies you have yes you have to close
it or else you leave that open energy
open and anything that wants to come and
hang out is now welcome to just flood
inch yeah and if that like there's steps
that you can do if you're opening you
know your your little
group and you feel like there's some
sort of really awful evil energy coming
in that you can close it and make sure
that that energy does not have the
ability to come manifest within the room
do you know I mean I mean I mean that's
help me if I'm wrong but this is only my
experience so there's no wrong answer
here I feel like this is all experience
based this is all like even for people
who haven't experiences this is my
experience talking to people who have
had experience yeah obviously let us
know in the comments like your
experiences or whatever and if you agree
with anything we're saying
I I feel like if I you know even this
discussion like I I one thing I feel
like I've learned in the last few years
I think being with you is that has an
impact of this a lot is to be respectful
of the whole the whole universe of
ghosts and anything like that because of
honestly mostly because of fear like I
don't want to be that person who was
just like scoffing at the idea of ghosts
and it's now like it's stupid and then
really I have a terrifying experience
like I don't want that mm and I think
that comes with like I don't know like
hearing you talk about it learning more
about it thinking about it you know just
trying to be a little bit cerebral about
it about it I think what's helped me the
most with ghosts in particular is
imagine if you were a ghost
I don't know I've joked about it in the
past like if I was a ghost I wouldn't
just watch somebody when they needed me
I'd be there all the time like hanging
out you know [ __ ] just doing whatever
the [ __ ] I want
but if you were a ghost you know maybe
you don't know what's going on maybe
you're just as scared as the person
who's seeing the ghost is so if you come
at it from that perspective like this
this thing isn't intentionally trying to
scare me
like you can feel it out maybe they are
maybe they're combative maybe they don't
want to be around you in which case
leave them alone
but a lot of times they're just they
just need a safe space to be a ghost you
know they just don't want people [ __ ]
with them and I feel like I can respect
that I can't you know because if you
were a ghost and you're like this this
right here this is my elliptical and if
anyone comes near it I will kick you
yeah wouldn't you just be like alright
dude this is your
man I'm gonna wheel this into the garage
and just you do you mr. ghost yeah let's
talk about that there's anything wrong
with that yeah maybe that's what I have
a long theory that I found I can read it
but the theory before that is basically
just ghosts are projections of the
person seeing them what does that mean
like if I have issues with something
like I don't know like I'm basically
projecting the ghosts into my own
reality because of my own experiences of
being only the only argument I have
against that is that it wouldn't explain
multiple sightings find multiple people
of the same apparition there you go even
less they're projecting the same thing
but that's unlikely no like the houses
the big you know plantation houses with
like yeah we see a little girl or a
woman yeah in the same outfit and they
can all describe her the same way I mean
I don't think that's something that we
really see the same go totally I don't
buy into that one yeah
so let's end on this one this is kind of
a complex one it's called the mask of
reason quantum theory of ghosts okay by
a professor max Bruin PhD I'm down and
he basically says I'll read a little bit
ghosts are created when the observers of
most emotions create a semi-permanent
indentation into the quantum tapestry of
the universe like the scent of a burnt
toast that remains long after the
offending bread is discarded ghosts are
impressions of emotions that remain long
after the cause has been resolved ghosts
therefore are formed not the dead formed
not from the dead but from the living
and their interactions with the world
around them the recording of events with
within the subatomic we've give gives
rise to an after image and depending on
the intensity of the emotion and
permeability of the quantum state
different types of ghosts can be created
negative emotions are many times more
likely to cause these effects the reason
for this is currently unknown though it
may have to do with the quantum spin of
the universe what are you thinking of
this I guess I'm I'm not buying it I
mean maybe that could offer so this is
I could offer some logical explanation
as to why all of a sudden when you live
in your house for 10 years and you start
seeing ghosts maybe fine but that
doesn't explain for the millions of
people that have seen something like a
door slam or you know a chair move or
for me personally a bed moving and
someone sitting on it that doesn't
explain the physicality of some of these
supernatural experience yes it might
explain here maybe it maybe in a sense
it does but it doesn't fully explain it
no that does not explain why a door
slams by itself
you didn't perceive the door slamming
you honestly I wouldn't count that out
completely what I wouldn't say that
that's completely unlikely like oh no
it's like who knows if you if if ghosts
are really just perception like no
matter how real it feels like right now
if that door shut right and I'm like
okay that door stone I was here I saw it
I heard it I felt the wind you did too
but then what if it's like if it's
revonnah thoris toes are falling
everyone else in the entire world we
could tell that story too but maybe it
really didn't happen and maybe we really
both just were in the same energy at the
same time and perceived that had
happened in the most real visceral sense
that we could ever that's possible but
my only problem with that is that you
have all these people all over the world
that you know when you say you hear a
story from me or you hear it from Rome
and all of a sudden that becomes real
like they I haven't heard one person
that's told me some mumbo-jumbo ghost
story every one that's had an experience
can tell you and swear to you up and
down how real it was and how everything
actually happened and that it's not a
perception why does it happen to a lot
of people across culturally all around
the world all I'm saying I'm not I don't
agree with this theory all I'm saying is
as devil's advocate it is that it's it's
definitely possible especially if you
think about like as much as you want to
rely on your own experience maybe just
maybe your experience is perceived you
know what I mean like it's not real
mm-hmm it's just a thought it
thought that I'd like to not just count
out because like [ __ ] it I just think
it's interesting to entertain that's all
well I buy into the parallel universes
yeah and I buy into angels and demons
and I buy into people like those there
are dead I bind all those two equally
and kind of in their own ways I don't
buy into things on a loop and I don't
buy into it's your perception hmm what
do you think what do you think hell is
is that a different podcast we already
talked about that yeah we did yes that's
right that's right really
yeah vici that's right [ __ ] Wow
it's crazy yeah that is crazy I don't
know I just think a lot more about yeah
last podcast now that we've done well
you know what purgatory is right yeah in
theory there you go
before you go to heaven foundation or
yeah or your next is so what if Earth in
your spirit form is purgatory and I'm
currently in purgatory no when your oh
oh god I got it so they haven't moved on
yet those have moved so that's that's
your purgatory and you know whatever
business or energy you need to let go of
as soon as you do you've reach your next
destination
who should explain why some ghosts have
existed in some places for years and
years and years and years like hundreds
of years and people claim to see the
same thing happening maybe because that
person or energy hasn't has still
refused to let go and they're there in
purgatory or their perception of time in
purgatory is a lot different than it is
due to I'm saying like if a ghost exists
for 100 years on earth maybe four then
that's like five minutes
yeah totally relative time um I thought
I was just gonna say [ __ ]
something about purgatory and ghosts
never mind I don't know I lost it yeah
the thought of the thought of your world
being another beings purgatory that's
kind of trippy because that means you're
currently experiencing what like what a
person is living in or existing and
they've died yeah right that means what
we are in heaven we are in hell we are
in a place where dead beings exist
mm-hmm or maybe they died in a different
universe and the earth is their
purgatory like they didn't even come
from Earth they came from somewhere else
and then they just ended up on earth as
purgatory mm-hmm it's all crazy to me
but I do think that they're real I feel
like people that don't deny any sort of
supernatural thing happening on earth
that deny everything like people who are
like humans are the only existing beings
right yeah and I apologize on the last
podcast people were very mad at me and
I've said and I'm so sorry I've chose
sort of the wrong words
because I said atheists who believe that
the human beings are the end-all be-all
I should have just said people who
believed it really had nothing to do it
you don't need to take shots at you just
sitting here talking I'm sorry for that
I did not mean to offend anyone guys
relax in case you didn't mean it but I
again along the ideas it does bother me
when people are like yeah none of it is
real all of its fake I'm like but
there's there's plenty of things that
you can't explain yeah no one can
explain for sure and I just maybe just
say me I don't believe in ghosts but
there are things that people can't
explain well like I don't believe in
ghosts because I haven't been given
reason to believe in ghosts not that's
not to say I'd finally finally want to
say they don't exist yeah violently
nothing exists I'll be the first to
admit that I wasn't I wasn't all the way
there but I was I was definitely in the
doubter party before and um you know I
always thought it was like like yeah
okay I grown adults talking about a
ghost or get a load of this like really
hmm
and it's it's really not something I
think that's something that I've kind of
it's a it's a belief that I've matured
into in a way like I've learned to kind
of keep my mind open in this sense when
I really felt like it didn't need to be
open you know but that's why I find it
interesting I also feel like so many
people now like it is the majority I
feel like of people now who believe in
ghosts people the majority of people now
believe in guys like
I'm just like I guess like on rent and
stuff like you know when you you like
you're amongst other people in their
opinions and then you get to kind of get
a gist of like what the majority feels
and what they the minority feels like
for me I always felt like the minority
was the people who believed in ghosts
and now I feel like it's the opposite I
feel like a lot of people believe that's
got outside to do something with red
it's changing demographic and that
there's a lot of young people I'm ready
and I've said this for forever about
Millennials and young kids now people
that are on the Internet the people that
you see on Twitter the people that are
consuming online media the because of
their exposure to the internet from such
a young age they just know things things
like aliens things like ghosts things
like conspiracy theories a healthy
skepticism of authority or things like
that they they just know things and it's
incredible to me like you know all it
takes is one or two pieces of evidence
and they don't they don't have some
life-changing shift of thought in their
mid-40s like they just like oh this is
the thing that exists cool all right I'm
gonna run with that I really think that
you might see that because of the
younger demographic on reddit now and
because they just know things they're
like yeah totally why the [ __ ] not her
instead of that like I don't know it
still doesn't fit into my worldview so I
really believe that there I was like
yeah totally
that's totally possible I think that's
one of the most important
characteristics of a lot of Millennials
they're open to anything and they're and
they're they're aware of the fact that
they are exposed to a lot of information
that people who are closed off the
technology and a lot of things like that
are not exposed to mm-hmm
kids in their technology like everything
yeah it's easier for them to be like
this is possible because I've seen
plenty of things that support it that
deny it that whatever but you know what
my opinion is it's a thing that may or
may not exist but that's why they can
make such funny jokes man because
they're just aware of things totally
hyper-awareness hyper hyper hyper diaper
good way to end the podcast anyways
please write us some ghost stories
intercom
and also tell us what you swear on that
it's true so what does that mean like I
swear on my dog
what does that mean like when you swear
on something you're like oh I can
believe them okay all right like if I'm
like I swear on peach this happened it
happened I'm not gonna swear on peach if
it didn't happen so just like swear on
something for me okay you really don't
have to do that you just tell us your
ghost stories unsubscribe if you don't
swear on anything leaves hanging out for
another spooky podcast yeah that was fun
that was fun and I don't know I'm just
I'm a believer of a lot of things I'm
open to a lot of things so if your
healthy skepticism of everything feel
free to chime in skepticism I like that
let me get that tattooed on my forehead
now guys if you want if you want to send
us suggestions on the next spooky
podcast I say we keep it spooky for all
dying and ghosts we also needed make
sure we do part two of both of these I
think at some point this in the last
weeks I feel like there's yeah well we
although we talked in general about
ghosts maybe we could do a podcast that
was just specifically ghost story yes or
we could maybe have a guest on with a
lot of good ghosts or something like
that
totally um but yeah let us know
suggestions for next week's podcast uh
we will see you guys next week for
another one check out the sponsors in
the description below we appreciate you
guys being here we love you ding fell
and I have a good week say bye make some
noises for us but to send us off
send us offices oh yeah it's so hard to
be alive
by
[Music]
[Music]